well I was gonna start what was the idea
for the short always focused on Aetna
and Jack Jack or was there any other
sort of thoughts there were other
thoughts for sure but it's something
that had been percolating sure probably
for a while probably ever since Brad
first wrote the scene when Bob drops off
the baby you know we're always talking
because you know these shorts tend to at
least more recent ones at least since
wall-e tend to be born out of the film
itself sure
so as we're making the film we tend to
talk about how this make a good DVD
shorter we should have the scene or that
scene so it'd been it been going for a
little while but it wasn't until
February that the producers asked me and
I said I think we should do this
what were the other ideas for the shorts
potentially you know nothing nothing
like fully baked you know I would have
loved to do a void short mm-hmm I love
that character mm-hm you know I wanted
to see more of that character but you
know in terms of time and budget and
things it's like they're we couldn't
have done it it would have been all new
sets and locations and characters and
all that and just couldn't do it how
early does production and development
start on a short like this for you guys
I mean you obviously need to see the
finished film I would think right no no
maybe the finished story you're not an
even finished story but at least some
some yeah it's good to know where the
story is headed mmm cuz often these show
a moment you don't see in the film these
short films but in general we try and
start at about six or seven months
before we need to deliver it they're on
a very accelerated timeline in this case
we started about four months before we
get it deliver it do you like working on
that sort of a celebrated timeframe is
that is that something that you enjoy or
I'll be the last is that strong
hesitation next time as first-time
director it was working at that pace was
was challenging
I think you know if there's a next time
for me then I'll be more familiar with
it but you know I was lucky to have just
come off the film and had worked very
closely with Brad and had a lot of his
things that he had given to me through
you know a mentorship essentially you
know having worked so closely with him
that I could apply how does the
development on a short compared to a
feature for you both we have we have a
lot of lead time and development on a
feature a couple of years probably with
a short it was like go clock's ticking
you know so not really a lot of
development time at all you know I just
started storyboarding straight out of
the gate maybe I don't know maybe half a
week that you know we were brainstorming
ideas yeah there's a shot that looks
like it'll stick we might throw that
into production
it's it's very piecemeal how much change
from sort of the initial conception of
an eddy to the finished product
there was about a minute minute and 10
seconds which was constantly changing
the Mozart section was the first thing
to go in production I boarded that you
know pretty quickly
because we knew we needed it we knew we
had that particular piece of music we
knew it caused the multiplication so
that was the first thing to go in but
everything the minute prior to that
where the powers was unfolding we
iterated on that endlessly as a test
what were those iterations well
different ways different powers
different ways that they bonded how do
we then we studied like shots where you
would get just get a quick read and so
that we could have some quick cutting
from for length so there's there's
iterations for
NEADS do you brainstorm different powers
for a job like what is the the
brainstorming session like for director
I can do this we handed it over to the
effects team okay you know when because
initially we weren't gonna have any new
powers like we have to use the powers
that we already have and it became clear
right away it's like we must show new
powers you know so we just threw it to
the effects team mm-hmm and they went
crazy with it they loved it was there
anything that was off the board that you
couldn't do effect wise yeah what was
what was one that you could I really
wanted to do an elastic baby okay how
would that work
what do you have we would have just
stretched like the last day oh yeah this
there's so much you can do
you